[Music]
those things
things are fine yeah it's hot isn't it
yeah it's hot all right
i have to say i like your pants i think
i told you about these pants earlier on
these pants baggy red pants these were
um
in tribute to a still image that i saw
one time of tom york
the lead singer of radiohead was doing a
photo shoot wearing very very baggy
black trousers and i thought man they
look cool and then i was walking around
and i saw a pair of trousers that were
red with the same kind of fit and i
thought i'll have them
and you look fantastic though they're
just cut off at the bottom
cut right off yeah did you do that yeah
well unfortunately if you had these
little hooks like kind of toggles on the
bottom and if you walked around barefoot
and you got your foot on them it was
like standing on a piece of lego so i
cut them off quite right
it allowed the trouser just to kind of
float around a little bit more kind of
gypsy like how's your week been it's
been pretty good i've been you know
desperately avoiding the sun yeah
because it's so hot yeah and trying to
keep my garden alive yeah so the thing
with me is i'm usually up around about 6
30
seven so between seven and about 9 30 i
can water the plants and then i have to
hide inside right go to the gym and then
i can't then water the plants until
probably closer to
six so then i run outside and water the
plants again until it gets dark so it's
just a whole practice of trying to keep
my plants alive you can you can see them
physically go from there
wilting give them some water
back up to feeling good good
good for you what about you yeah it's
been a good week actually i did a bit of
cooking did a bit i am surfing
it's been good actually yeah did a
little bit of music yeah good week i was
on the west side and i said i might come
over and you said all right i've got a
few things come going on i don't think
you said mate
i'm coming over
and you said okay i've got a few things
coming going on but come over
and then i thought wow sounds like it's
a bit of a hassle so then i said i'm not
coming over and you said why i didn't
answer because i was driving and then
later on you just sent me a photo of my
dinner and you said this is the dinner
that i bought for you and i thought oh
it's quite angry it's quite expensive as
well did you have it yourself did you
did it get caught in your throat you'd
choke on it no it's still in the fridge
i'll eat it tonight treat yourself i
will i know i'm sorry i thought i wanted
to get home before the traffic yeah
and that's what i did well well done but
to be honest my dinner last night was uh
half a bowl of soup and a bag of crisps
that's all right so i'll probably open
this sip no as a side dish so i probably
would have benefited from
coming over to your house you would have
enjoyed it
now this week we have a fantastic guest
oh well i mean if you're talking
lord there are rings which we sometimes
do sometimes this would be one of your
well certainly top three
there were i believe
number one number two number three
number four on the call sheet yeah
i think were you three i was four i
think i think i was three then
number one elijah wood had him number
two yep is our guest today
the fantastically talented
sean astin
who i believe played sam wise gamji
in the lord of the rings who later on
became known as sam gardner did you know
that some gardener yeah he was they gave
him the name sam gardner because of his
ability to till the soil
a bit like yourself
and he became
mayor of the shire mere gardener
he's on our screen he's on the tv screen
two no wait i was gonna do i was gonna
do bad math though i was gonna say
two-thirds of the hobbits but that's not
right is it it's three-fourths of the
hobbits is that right
three of us yeah right he's not very
good at math i don't know if you know
that about um sean oh god well i just
sort of i just figured it out just now
because i'm never good at math either
but three quarters i got yeah yeah i'm
bad i actually had to ask billy the
other day what was the thing oh i said
i've got 15 plants i want to plant them
in even numbers around my garden how do
i do the maths for that so billy tell me
now with that that's how bad i am in
maths because it has to be i think you
need 30
you need 30. and then you can have 15
and 15 which would give you a total
yeah it's got to be a whole number yeah
right because you can't
you can't have half a plan so was it
three did we hit upon the number of
three i think you had five groups of
three
which that works but he wanted four
groups and you can't have four groups
into 15.
no not of no you can't anyway sean this
isn't this is not gonna this is not
gonna work for the audio listeners but
there are a lot of people that watch
this on video tell us if they could see
the inside of my mind with the math
wheels turning they might be slightly
more entertained because it's a
kaleidoscope so
i want to buy you a plant to make it
even but then we sorted it out where
there's
it's evenly divisible by five so well
sean
yeah of course buy me a plan i mean why
wouldn't you buy me a plan just because
with pals but you know you probably
wouldn't need to buy one because you
know you've got plenty behind you yeah
where in the amazon jungle do we find
you sean
yes it's just home you can hear the dogs
now
christine just got home so all the dogs
in the bark for me but where's the
backyard nice how many dogs
there's five
five we had like two and then covet hit
and so instead of like trying to get one
of those online therapists we just kept
getting a dog every six months wow
dogs how many daughters now seven eight
uh it's three daughters yet the little
one just turned 16 yesterday hey wow wow
i still picture ally as being like
three and a half four
so ally for anyone listening and you
don't know ally was the daughter that
sean um
had already when he started lauda rings
and she was a big part of her
adventure in life down in new zealand
and she was always on set and and she
had birthday parties and we were all
part of that yeah so so how old was she
uh i she was three when we went down
there uh celebrated fourth
and fifth birthdays wow down there you
guys came that we had that one party we
had the party in the background
yeah party in the bag yeah yeah which is
awesome and then everybody drew we still
have so we covered the inside of one of
those easy up tents with uh
with brown paper brown paper and then
everybody drew
who made drawings and their names and
everything else so we only tore that and
we have it in the garage so uh if you
ever need to see that i think we can we
can yeah that's that's one of our
keepsakes there but um but yeah so but
she was seven when the final uh premiere
happened in new zealand so it was uh
yeah she was a she was a benchmark to
watch as we
yeah and then you have memory of it
um
it's um
when it comes time for all of us to do a
photo shoot or something yeah i don't i
think you might have caught seen this at
one point but
you know over the years they'll have us
do you know a reunion photo shoot for
this magazine or that event or whatever
and
when she comes to it it takes her days
to recover from it
she she she cries it's like
she she doesn't she it like she you know
she's a very intelligent she went to
harvard she's a very brilliant girl and
everything but she regresses back to
that time and she
uh
i don't know it it is deeply emotional
for much more so than me i'm like yeah
hi guys you know
she is very
she's very emotional
i love you yeah i mean she became
awesome
like
we were kind of
surrogate
babysitters and yeah yeah like our
little niece
yeah uncles every time we went for
dinner because as a group we all went
for dinner very often
you know the four hobbits and orlando
and you know there was a core group that
very often went for dinner and ali would
consistently be
running around the table spending time
with all of us and hanging out and
drawing on our knee and all this kind of
stuff so it is i mean i'm sure it must
be bizarre for you too sean but it's
very bizarre to think
as the
pre-drinking hours
right because you know
at a certain point you know she's young
and would have to go to bed and then the
next morning you guys would look
different
and have
so uh yeah no definitely um
yeah that was that to me that was one of
the greatest things about being able to
do it was to give her
uh it was an incredible experience for
all of us but for something happens you
know
billy in your mind as a parent you
something changes in your brain and you
you see everything through their
perspective and i was having that
experience
down there and um
so
yeah so she just to see her
yeah and you were it you you guys were
the experience like i got to give her
this experience and the experience
was you lot yeah yeah yeah
so talking about that then
uh the experience and and seeing it
through someone else's eyes and stuff
can you what is your first memory like
can you remember coming off the plane
for the first time coming into new
zealand or what is the first thing that
you think oh yeah i remember that like
getting the script for the first time
what what was it
uh
well if we look at it like that like the
first memory of of kind of landing yeah
it was a little bit hazy on the airport
and the transfer but i do remember we
didn't get to go straight to the hotel i
think we went straight to stone street
who were you with
when you said we had
well
uh
christine and ali were with me but i
mean there were other
were you not there we're never together
no i guess maybe i came in with orlando
right
i don't i would come look i'm looking at
his brain
[Laughter]
[Music]
rubber suits at stone street studios
because everything was it you know it
was an abandoned paint factory and every
hallway had some other
thing that was you know the here's the
miniatures and here's to this and
at a certain point i remember thinking
i'm gonna die from exhaustion but they
they the mentality they set coming off
the airplane was you know you know this
is a work day you know so we're gonna
and pete wants you to come to stone
street straight away and he wants to
visit you i remember
seeing the pre-visualization
of
and they said okay we really want to
show you what we're working on with the
software and we had just traveled like
15 hours you know and yeah and i'm
looking at it and they're like and you
can see this and it's just leaves it's
just
it just leaves
a part of something spectacular i mean
it's gonna have great leaves i can tell
you that much
but but i also remember um oh do i even
go there with it the there was a um
the urukai outfits yeah
the the rubber suits the villain you
know the the disgusting things that
those poor guys had on for months at a
time yeah there was one that looked like
uh harvey weinstein
oh yeah that's right i mean it was it
was a
it was a dead it was an absolute
photo real
image of harvey weinstein on this
villainous urukai rubber suit
the mask or whatever yeah and i was like
i didn't know if i was supposed to say
anything i did not at that point know
about miramax and
how they had initially developed the
film and the whatever issues they had
with
with uh with that man who's uh who's
not doing well now but anyhow uh yeah so
that's that's it
that was my first you know that was the
first memory and then going over that um
hotel across the street from the um
from the museum the
papa museum yeah ten points for anyone
who remembers the hotel duxton oh well
done ten points yeah yeah
yeah i'm sorry sean i know i've been
listening to the podcast so i know how
important points are very important
we're very competitive very competitive
um
i flew in with john ruiz davis and i had
the exact same thing as you sean i
remember thinking okay cool we'll get to
the hotel i'm probably gonna have the
day off now maybe the day off tomorrow
and then we'll start and i got a phone
call half an hour into that day and they
said there's a car picking you up and i
just thought there must be some mistake
you must know that i've just done a
32-hour flight
you're thinking about tomorrow and then
we're like no you're going to come in
see pete he wants to give you a tour of
the studio and i think you're right sean
i think he had made a specific statement
with all the actors as soon as you hit
the ground in new zealand you're mine
and we are at work you know
yeah yeah yeah we don't want you to to
develop that that uh the relaxation
mode right you know you are coming to a
spa
you know you know you're not going to
have a bit of a tour and walk around the
city and see how it feels and like nope
you're there i also remember very
clearly walking into that room with you
guys with the swords laid out on the
table
right all right
we were gonna do
we're gonna do this
at that um
that barracks it was that uh
i think it might have actually been do
they have a navy does it
yeah i think it was a navy back because
it was just like a submarine base or
something yeah it was an army
army barracks we were in an army
barracks and they you know from the 60s
or 70s or something like that and we
went in there and we all we got to
choose our
our swords and and then uh bob anderson
the gorgeous wonderful brilliant
legendary uh
sword master who taught errol flynn and
who else did he did the star wars
uh darth vader yeah yeah obi-wan yeah
princess bride he did that
yeah and he was teaching us and we were
good at it i thought we were very good
at it well you and billy had like a
routine didn't you yeah when you said we
were good at it you mean we were good
i don't know if elijah and the dom were
that guy was too busy smoking cigarettes
i could never have a sword fight with
him he's always out smoking soon
[Laughter]
when you pay for a job site you should
know what you're getting
get indeed and only pay for quality
candidates that meet your must-have
requirements
when hiring gets hard you need indeed
the job site that makes hiring
incredibly simple just attract interview
and hire in fact with indeed you can do
all your hiring in one place even
interviewing
don't just hope your perfect candidate
will find you
indeed's hiring tools help you cut
through the noise to hire faster and
smarter in fact indeed instant match
provides a list of quality candidates
whose resumes are on indeed the moment
you post a sponsored job
indeed knows how important that is to
make the most of your recruiting hours
and dollars
with indeed you can save time and money
by setting your must-have qualifications
and only paying for the quality
candidates that meet them
get started right now
with 75 dollar sponsored job credit to
upgrade your job post at indeed.com
slash onion
get a 75 dollar credit at indeed.com
onion
indeed.com slash onion offer valid
through september 30th terms and
conditions apply if you're like us
you're probably sick of scrolling
through mindless programs that you don't
even want to watch well i tell you what
me and dom love
one dream
fantastic streaming service that your
brain will never get enough of there's
just so much to explore we love it
one dream offers endless opportunities
to learn something with thousands of
hours of video and audio
fascinating documentaries helpful to
do's and
answers to every question that you've
ever asked if you're familiar with the
great courses plus then you already know
one dream it's the same great service
only now it's bigger and better you're
going to love it
some of the stuff i've been listening to
lately and watching
mind-blowing science that's where i get
all my facts about black holes another
fantastic one great revolutions of
modern history i was looking at all the
revolutions in france and russia and
united states as well great stuff
we know you love one dream so we put
together a special offer just for our
listeners a free month's trial of
unlimited access just go to our special
url wondrous.com slash onion that's
um dot w-o-n-d-r-i-u-m.com
slash onion think of how much you'll
learn in a month go to onedream.com
onion
what was the what was the reason for
that party that we ended up doing uh we
did a sword fence for it was it
the start of this that was a shoot-off
party yeah that was the kickoff
so that was a party to say we're about
to start filming yeah and they did the
maori thing there right a little maori
blessing there i think and and bob
anderson specifically asked me and um
not me and um me and sean whatever to do
um you know to show everyone how amazing
cause he's so intimidated by dumb yeah
do you guys remember i tell you what a
big one was for me
i tell you a big one for me was the
remember the previz that pete showed us
at his house so pete has got this
wonderful
house on a bunch of different levels and
there's a lot of nooks and crannies and
corners in pete's house and obviously
the house itself has been built with
extensions and it's kind of strange
shaped yes very kind of you know idiots
very kind of
you know pete jackson centric there's a
lot of like sean said doorways to places
in corners of rooms you're like well
that makes no sense but whatever he
brought over
the four hobbits guaranteed i think
orlando as well at that point we the
early boys that were there
ian was working ian was with us and i'd
never seen him yet because i drove him
home after oh right nice i've never seen
pete's cinema before because it's hidden
away behind a door you don't even think
he's got a small kind of screening room
i'd never seen a personal screening it's
just garage
right oh right is it a converted garage
yeah
that makes sense now when you think
about the geography of it i can i can't
get the geography oh really it's one
little door you go in yeah and you turn
immediately right and there's a there's
a couple of little steps and then
suddenly to your left there's a big
screen maybe 10 lazy boys i remember the
room but i couldn't if someone put me in
the kitchen and said find that room
right there's no way i would find it
it's close to the kitchen for sure but i
remember i'd never seen a personal
screen room before didn't even know that
pete had one obviously pete's not going
to say hey i've got a personal screen
room it doesn't really matter we go in
i thought he told us we were going to
watch the previews
i wasn't really sure what previs was i
was just nodding along going oh great
yeah previous sat down he had a popcorn
making machine do you remember yeah so
we all had popcorn
and there was anything that you wanted
to drink i was at that point completely
addicted to bundaberg ginger beer i was
drinking like four or five a day i had
no idea there was like 80 of your daily
sugar needs in one bottle
and we sat down and we watched this
gassy yeah for sure we watched this
relatively clunky
although although obviously very
functional
previz which is an animated simplified
version of what they're going to shoot
with the actors right you're you're
quite uh you you know you're a hollywood
guy you understand movies and all that
shawn
it's previous yeah is that a name that
meant something before then
well sean was going to say animatic
right because i think they work on it
the animatic right they called it an
animatic because what they did was
storyboards those uh those wonderful
drawings that they would do for an
action sequence is when you usually see
them uh you know where they'll draw
you know what the over the shoulder shot
looks like and then they draw an image
it's a still you know sketch of
you know a wide shot of minister or
something like that and then they would
literally film
those
storyboards kind of like ken burns you
know the ken burns effect where he's got
a still image and the camera's going
down so you so you you're sort of you
see
a soldier in the civil war and then you
kind of go closer and you see that he's
got a letter in his hand or something
like that so it's it's basically a
moving
uh
image of the storyboards and then previz
is the
the
digital
sequences little short digital sequences
where they would have
strange looking
uh you know
anamorphic looking characters in a
swordfight kind of floating or something
like that and then they and then you'd
see you know the nazgul in yeah and they
would actually animate that you know
yeah thing so so yeah i remember
watching that and then i remember i mean
it was so long
and they also had our
um they had um
they had our characters actors had read
and read the voices for our characters
that's right
so and i remember thinking
that the
the samwise gamji voice was pretty good
and i was nervous right you know
was there a point i'm sure i'm sure
we don't want to go over wrote things
the subjects and stuff but we billy and
i have talked before about that moment
where you realize
wow this movie is huge i had him over
moment walking around bag end was there
a specific moment for you sean where you
thought you knew it was big but you
didn't know it was quite that big until
that moment
well there was
a succession of them
the first the first one was when i was
at home in los angeles and got in the
part and someone came over with the
script
with this the three screenplays right
and when they set it on the
table it made a loud thud sound
most scripts make a kind of a flap but
this made a thud
and and you opened it up and it had
a fake name
it had a fake name oh my god there's a
horse ping in the back can you hear that
no we can't hear a horse pissing
[Laughter]
so there's jamboree it said on the
script
and i was confused i'm easily confused
billy can tell you and and i
uh and then i realized that they were
doing it so that if you were at a coffee
shop or something and you read it people
would not see that it was lord of the
rings so i was a part of something that
was so important it had to be kept a
secret
and then i opened it up and i don't know
how many movies i'd done where there was
watermarking on the screenplay where
your name was there
so but on every page sean astin written
big across the page and uh which is
totally distracting
absolutely distracting i wish i could
have gone back and and uh maybe put like
samwise or something different because i
every page you turn instead of getting
involved in the story and involved in
the characters i'm just reminded of how
important i am my name is
big across the page i still hear that
but then anyone does that right why
because i always feel like somehow i'm
gonna like
that's gonna get out because of me yeah
and then the page is gonna be there with
my name watermarked all over i can prove
it now and people put it in the most
stupid things now don't they like you
get any pages for anything yeah there's
your name all over and i just get
visions of
you know some leaked screenplay and it's
me have you written a screenplay billy
you must have written a screenplay i've
written a fantastic i've written and
they're apart for sean of course
sincerely i hope so for god's sake i'm
now getting over it in my head to make
sure there's a purpose
right one damn it man do whatever
whatever i'm told i will do it i know
but i if you wrote it in one of those
we're going i'm going to watermark it
and send it to you with sean astin all
over it
i'll send you the the script if you can
do it by hand that would be great even
just by hand put my name in it's like
you're in trouble you have to write my
name 95 times but uh but you can just
push a button it's one button you click
a button and then it spits out a thing
with your name or somebody else's name
so i know with scripts that i've written
you feel all of a sudden very important
that you can make it uh
you can make you can make people
obligated to you in some way by putting
their name on it
now we're so sorry but i love you we cut
you off there so so you can big moment
for one thing how did he get the script
did you get the script before you
arrived
i got the script before i got on the
plane yeah i didn't i didn't get the
script till i got to wellington i don't
know there's a moment i really remember
i got off the flight with uh orlando we
sat in a car
and janine the producer's assistant
turned back to us and gave us
a leather bound folder
with the fellowship of the ring in it
right and that is the first time i've
seen this i'm down in new zealand and i
haven't even seen this i got that quite
late so that might be the reason why i
got it then but i also remember emailing
pete jackson and said
don't
send the script to the scotsman because
scottish people will leak information
like that if you do send it make sure
there's a watermark all over it yeah
because um sean probably because
scotland is farther away than me well
maybe that's it maybe it's still on its
way but it could also have been because
you were a goony and and stuff yeah you
get special treatment probably goonies
do get absolutely special prefer
treatment
that's true for good reason i was uh
you were the person that i was the most
enamored to me because so much of my
rainy day uh childhood moments were
consumed with raiders of the lost ark
the dark crystal and the goonies it was
just it's just a magical
movie amazing
um so i remember meeting you
vividly but we all spent so much time
together sean
making those films especially the first
film but i would put a strong argument
forward to say that possibly you
more than anyone else maybe because you
had a young daughter at home
were
the most
kind of
holding
so much of the weight of the movie on
your shoulders even someone like elijah
who's significantly younger than than
you
seem to be getting through his days with
a lot less of the the weight of the
piece than you do do you think that's
fair
yeah i think that's fair yeah the the um
i mean
there's so much there's so much to
unpack first of all i was fat
so i was definitely carrying the weight
through the experience of working on
those
plus you had that backpack which is
knotted
on the back but oh my gosh the backpack
was
yeah i you know when i met elijah at the
moment sofitel hotel right next to the
beverly center you lived pretty close to
there yeah um i did dom for a while
and uh we we went there to have a wig a
wig fitting with peter owen and i
remember thinking how cool it was i get
to wear a wig and then also why do i
have to wear a wig and uh and peter
drawing this wonderful drawing of the
silhouettes of the hobbits you know and
and why that you want their silhouettes
to match with each other and that guy's
just incredibly brilliant um and when i
met elijah down in the lobby we saw each
other like from across the lobby some
star-crossed lovers moment and we raced
to each other and just embraced and held
each other and we were laughing and so
excited and then you know i was 29 and
he was 19.
and i pulled him away from my my body i
had my hands on his shoulders and i said
are you ready for this you know kind of
self-important you know are you ready
like i know i'm a wise old man at 29 or
are you ready for this young one and
then we spent two years with him proving
how much more ready he was for it
here's a service you should use if you
use the internet
expressvpn
i know most of you are thinking well i
don't need to i'll just put it on
incognito mode well let me tell you
something incognito mode does not hide
your activity doesn't matter what mode
you use
and in the us
internet service providers are legally
allowed to sell your information to ad
companies
expressvpn is an app that re-roots your
internet connection through their secure
servers
that will keep all your information
secure by encrypting a hundred percent
of your data with the most powerful
encryption available
most of the time
we don't even know that it's switched on
expressvpn is available on all your
devices phones computers
even your smart tvs so there's no excuse
for you to not use it
protect your online activity today with
the vpn that was rated number one by
cnet
visit our exclusive link expressvpn.com
slash onion and you can get an extra
three months free on a one year package
that's e x p r e s s v p n dot com slash
onion
expressvpn dot com slash onion
to learn more
no matter how you feel about getting
back out there there's no denying it's
an adjustment
and when the world gets too loud
something that i like to do is i pop in
my recon wireless earbuds they are
brilliant sometimes you just need some
upbeat music you know to pump up your
day a little bit
or maybe even stay calm with a guided
meditation
i was on my first flight for quite some
time the other day there and i just
popped in my recon wireless earbuds and
it was nice to hear some of my old
playlists again
of course you can always use it to
listen to podcasts say for instance me
and dom
right in your ear fantastic
they come with a bunch of gel tips for
your comfort so they'll fit like no
other earbuds and
they don't stick out your ears like
others
recon
have a 32 hour battery life so you can
listen to whatever you want when you
want for a really long time
create your own soundtrack with recon
right now
listeners can get 15
of the recon order at buy recon dot com
slash onion that's by raycon dot com
slash onion to save 15 on recons
by recon dot com slash onion
you know there were financial things
that were burdening my brain
though during that time um
we had bought things you wouldn't even
think about affect people's life but but
if i if i put the layers on top of it
now 20 years later you know and try and
think because i definitely did i
definitely
my experience was a much harder
um
more laden it was a more laden
experience i think that it wasn't harder
we all
didn't sleep the same and we all
had you know little things little
injuries here and there and but for some
reason i definitely carried it um
i re i remember there were all these
moments leading in
where i was hoping did you so the have
you talked about the bakshi version the
raf bakshi version of uh lord of the
rings from the 1970s yeah here and there
the the tel
yeah the television version first of all
it is
it was absolutely ahead of its time with
some of the i think they call it
rotoscoping some of what they did with
the ring wraiths and yeah and some of
the sound design was really really for
thing but it was mostly terrible
it was mostly really really really awful
and the hobbits there's like readings if
you read the lord of the rings right
like the hobbits are these bumbling
bursting into tears terrified hiding
behind things like you could actually
have hobbits that were
that are if you depicted them in a movie
the way they're written
it wouldn't be credible that they're
heroic later at the end right you know
it's like in in literature you can you
can enjoy that they're like oh the
hobbits are bursting into tears yeah but
in the in the back she version
they're really plump all of them yeah
and oh mr frodo i don't know what i'm
gonna do
i don't know what i'm gonna be doing mr
fraud and you're like i remember going
to pete and saying like do we have to do
it like that like i really don't want to
do it like that and so i feel and he was
like no we don't have to do it like that
but i definitely felt like through the
whole movie i was always afraid that
something was going to be that it wasn't
going to be right that it would end up
looking
we'd end up looking too silly in the
wrong ways like you you guys
thank god for you guys
right you found you made humor in the
way that the hobbits are intended to
have humor if it was just up to me
i was like serious all the time which is
funny
when juxtaposed against something else
but if it was just that all the time it
would be boring and well i wonder if
some of that is i wonder if some of that
is sam though right sean i mean sam is
kind of laden with the responsibility of
keeping frodo around and he has to be
the serious one who says to gandalf and
the rest of the fellowship of the ring i
will take care of him i am his steward
you have to be
the responsible one i wonder how much of
that is sam coming into your world you
know
i uh i i don't know where once where i i
don't know where i stop and he starts in
that in that sense i remember like i
played at that as an idea
right like i remember one night we were
at the pub early early early in the
shooting like even before shooting
you're in rehearsals and elijah uh
locked his keys in his
in his flat and i was like i'll take
care of it
[Laughter]
so i i sorted out a locksmith i went in
there and got it and i remember coming
in and you guys were all sitting with
the drink and he looked like he was 35
years old the way he carried his
cigarette and his drink and i'm like
trying to get my head around that this
19 year old kid and uh and i bring him
his key and he's like oh thank you so
much like exactly as frodo would like he
just
that
that's how that would be
yeah
because i remember i remember the day
that that barry osborne and pete
came well barry osborne was there sorry
p jackson was there all the time and
barry osborne came to set i think the
first day when we did the
under the wooded log moment and they had
said to the four of us hey guys if you
could just wait behind when we rap
because we want to talk to you about
something and me in my own sense of
naivety was just like oh whatever
they're gonna say we're so stoked you
guys are with us day one we're so
excited for this thing we'll have a
little whatever glass of champagne a
little huddle whatever billy didn't seem
to be in any way tweaked elijah didn't
and you immediately sean got the four of
us in a huddle and said what do you
think that is about and i thought
nothing and you said it's something it's
something and i thought no no sean's way
off and he was bang on something had
happened but you you i think that's the
thing you have the no like we we'd all
been in
indie movies and stuff but you'd been in
big movies before that you know and you
you've grown up in that world and i
remember that because i just thought i
didn't even think anything they want to
say well don't say i
i don't know they're going to do another
costume call tomorrow or something i
don't know but you grabbed this and said
they've seen the rushes they hate it
someone's getting fired i think you
might have said someone's getting fired
well they couldn't they couldn't have
they couldn't have seen the russians yet
because of the first thing we ever did
actually they could have seen
what we would remember they did the
wardrobe uh tests with us they took us
out in the parking lot and they created
tape on the ground and they were like
just
wander around
in character that's right the most
awkward thing ever right and so we we
had we thank god i was so happy that sam
was stoic because i didn't have to do
anything right but but i watched you
guys trying to you know just figure out
what the [ __ ] to do and then like
so but they had said that if they had
seen it and they liked it and they had
approved the wardrobe so i wasn't
worried about the that but then but when
they do you remember when they took us
to a special place yeah i don't even
know where the place was and they opened
the door
and it was a big empty room with four
chairs set in it take a seat
like a firing squad
and
we walked in and we sat down and i just
remember being like oh man this is not
good yeah and they came and it was tim
who told it wasn't it it was tim
tim was the one who told us i think yeah
that that
yeah and it was really horrible horribly
sad um so just for anyone
yeah for anyone listening or watching
what we're talking about here is the
fact that stuart townsend who was for a
while going to be playing aragorn had at
that point left the project and they
told the four hobbits who were on their
first day and the first day at work none
of us knew what was going on sean almost
knew before it happened what was going
on so i wonder if you were carrying that
shirt
i absolutely was 1 000 carrying it with
me until the last day
you know you can be replaced because
they can just go in and just do the face
shots and put the face of whoever they
want of any new person over the body
that you've been
moving around for two years in the in
the thing you're basically the body
double that they could put the face on
and your voice uh yeah i was absolutely
aware of that the whole time but but the
thing was you know
in a way they
they knew it was gonna hurt us because
another one of the big things that made
it that you knew it was going to be
massive was that we had six weeks of
preparation yeah that's never that never
that just doesn't happen and for six
weeks we got to become really good
friends with stuart yeah and you know
you could see he's the only one who wore
it harder than me for sure yeah he's he
was not he he couldn't he couldn't get
his uh his spirit around how hard it was
going to be to do it and and um
and and that that was another one there
were there were a lot of things with
that movie for all of us i think
right that
they were they you just had to there was
like
a loss of innocence or something or or
just
the the heaviness of
big decision making you know and and
consequential decision making
consequential for all the different
people they were hiring to do all the
different jobs consequential for
you know everyone's the the economics of
everyone's lives a little bit which
that's the other thing i said it at the
beginning like the economics weighed on
me as much as that and being fat
literally phys i had run the la marathon
like three months before filming and i
was i was
135 pounds and skinny i mean like real
skinny and then i wanted to get that job
so i got fat
there's no time in the next two years
i can't like i have to be fat and if you
don't see yourself i remember looking in
the mirror in the makeup bus
and like
who is this fat [ __ ] looking at me and i
can't see the real me anymore
i can't i can't see me
well let me ask you what was what was
that fat diet because i'm sure there's a
lot of actors out there that might have
to put on weight quite quickly what was
your diet was it ice cream and chocolate
what did you do what didn't you do
okay do you remember jeremy woodhead
i remember that jeremy woodhead was was
the uh was
makeup artist he was my makeup artist
first of course it's one of the only
male makeup eyes yeah yeah
i do remember yeah and then and then
yeah and and
and ian mckellen stole him from me
that's how i experienced him
as a thief
that that benighted english legend stole
my the makeup artist i like so much but
um we went to play tennis
at the there's a tennis center like an
athletic center in wellington and uh we
were we were going on five or six
different times it was it had become
you know i was getting in shape i was
really enjoying it they were sweating
and that the you know and and uh
but i think it's there someone took a
picture and put it in the in the
newspapers on the cover of the newspaper
it was national
news in new zealand that was like kind
of a star sighting right but with lord
of the rings like they they'd hidden us
away from cameras and stuff and uh and
it said that i was coming out of the
tennis center and
pj had this look when i walked in the
next day and i was like oh no
i'm like in trouble for working out
and uh and he said uh he showed he had
the he had it he showed it to me and i
was like
you know busted i don't know what i'm
supposed to say and he said more lollies
for mr aston please you know
he was like and they have those gummy
horrible candies that
were would definitely clog your arteries
after just a small handful of them yeah
but
yeah the trick was in weightlifting
for like a month before coming
to new zealand and then stopping
weightlifting and continuing to eat yes
okay so your body
thinks it's
yeah you wouldn't know you two don't
know you just drink all you want you
don't put on an ounce it's very
upsetting
we're getting there sean we are getting
there just to go back to what we talked
about earlier on about all of us being
exhausted and tired i have this very
vivid memory and i wonder if either one
of you can geographically place this for
me we are on location
i think that shawn and elijah had just
started to do
some climbing of mount mordor not sure
what you and i were doing specifically
but we were working and we got a message
probably from elijah who was with sean
that they
were finishing a very long day coming
back to the hotel that we were staying
at at like nine ish and that they'd
broken you guys turn around and you guys
had to be back on set at something like
being picked up at five in the morning
and elijah said to us
can you and billy are you and billy
around just to grab a quick dinner
because sean and i are both exhausted
and we said yeah we were in the bar
having a drink elijah showed up
before sean i don't know what sean was
doing elijah kind of came over to the
table still covered in mud from the day
not really got all of his makeup off and
he was like oh just gonna order a quick
dinner and we'll sit and we said yeah
and then sean came over and you kind of
collapsed almost onto the table put your
arms down on the table and we're just
like oh i can't believe this is it was
something like the seventh or eighth day
in a row that they'd broken
their turnaround and you ordered food
and the two of you ate with us for
probably 45 minutes and then you
immediately crashed and we're up the
next day do you guys remember where that
was or do you remember have that memory
no no sounds like every day it could
have been an entire year i just remember
sean coming over and and his whole his
head and shoulders and and chest just
collapsing on the table kind of half
laughing half crying and then looked up
at us and just said i can't believe
they're breaking i'll turn around again
you keep saying break your turn around
there was no such thing right that's
true yeah that's true
not a union
yeah well we should explain that let's
explain people listening so you guys
know that my mother patty duke my late
mother was a president of the screen
actors guild in the mid 1980s so the
union
and there are different unions in
different countries um
i say to you guys because i don't really
know that much about
um i worked under a sac contract in
england but anyhow so um certain rules
are established guidelines like you have
to have um
12 hours between the time you
rap and the time you cut you're called
back for the next day or sometimes it's
10 hours or something like that
and it's it's a rule and if they break
the rule then they have to pay
900 bucks or something like that so
usually as an actor you're hoping they
break your turn around because you
really want that extra 900 bucks but um
when we got to new zealand it was not in
a union space it was not a union project
so uh really
you guys know like our
quote-unquote turnaround was just based
on what they thought
we could
handle
right like you had you get to make the
ears the hobbit ears and the hobbit wig
and the hobbit feet off and that all
took probably an hour a little over an
hour at night time to get all the
alcohol on you know because it lets the
glue loose and everything and most of
the time not most of them but a lot of
the time it wouldn't even get all the
glue off just like you know what i'd
rather i'd rather have an extra half
hour of sleep than get all the cloth
that you're just gonna reapply in
another
10 hours nine hours so but a lot of
times you know you'd and then we'd have
to come in early stand on a box and have
our feet done at you know
4 35 5 30 in the morning something like
that so you know you come in at say five
and you work until it gets dark at 6 00
6 30 and you finally leave by seven get
home get something to eat turn around go
back right away again it was not it was
it was hard it was it was really really
really really hard yeah so
but i mean it also
you realize what you're capable of
you know yeah you realize the value of
the sacrifices that people have made to
help get rules like that put in place
but you also realize like i can actually
tolerate a lot more the the one thing
that really was amazing to me about um
our experience was the crew
the crew was indefatigable i mean they
they literally would work you know 15 16
17 hours and come right back and they
were always
ready to go happy fired up you know
maybe in the two years we were there one
time i saw them
decide that they collectively weren't
happy and they wanted to uh talk to the
producers about it and they got a
bump or something like that but um
but yeah you know it's it's amazing to
um i mean people think of acting it's
not that hard right like it's it's it's
it's not like
digging ditches or something or you know
real manual labor where people work
harder but it is it is hard and it the
the men you know you have to be
kind of
ready all day long ready to you know at
any given moment to do to do your thing
to have your memory tested and to
be able to you know do what someone else
is telling you to do
one of my favorite things not acting is
uh that i don't have to do what other
people tell me to do
yeah except billy when bill tells you to
do something then yeah he's the boss
when we had elijah on we we got into a
a big music conversation which concluded
with us talking about was there a
specific album or a specific song
that kind of summed up
new zealand for you was there any
particular
song or music or something like that
that you thought well that that is my
new zealand experience in an album
well when i was
15
i did a movie uh a whitewater
rafting movie i don't know if we ever
talked about i don't think we ever
talked about this uh with kevin bacon
it's a classic it's not the cat it's not
the white water rafting movie with david
strathearn and meryl streep that was his
other white water rafting movie ours was
the one you haven't heard about and uh
we we kept going around
to differ we went to canada a couple of
times we went up to the sierra nevadas
because they were trying to get this
white water rafting see canoeing
sequence to look spectacular so they
finally figured out down on the koara
river in the south island in queenstown
would be where we could shoot it so and
i was 15. well we flew to auckland
and i had because i was underage i had a
a a friend a guardian joseph giuseppe
pepe pascarelli with this big italian
mustache like mario mustache uh and
we we drove
the full length of the island
together
and we only had one cassette tape
and the cassette tape was billy joel's
greatest hits
so
i think
i don't know i might have come with the
rental car
but i literally uh i mean to me i don't
know okay so for lord of the rings it's
probably something different but when i
think of new zealand and and you know
any time throughout the
when we were trying to remember because
we were remembering what everyone played
in our makeup trailers
and
we i couldn't remember what music you
were playing and dom did think it was
billy yeah i said billy joel's great i
think i actually said great
of all of the music that elijah played
for us the hundreds of hours of music
that elijah played for us there's one
song
that hit me the most that i that i when
i'm running if i if it's in my
playlist when i'm running i will
immediately go back to that it's um
it's it's called driftwood oh by travis
yeah so that album that album was the
thing that defined new zealand for me
between billy elijah and myself we
became very territorial over the stereo
and i think there were times where you
said well let me have a go let me have a
go and i seem to remember the time where
we said okay sean you can go
it was billy joel's greatest hits and i
love uptown girl piano man come on and
do you remember christopher lee putting
on some music was it metal yeah but with
him speaking over there he had a few
metal albums
i was i was shocked when you put that on
amazing i remember that i rapped on the
same day as christopher lee
and oh i thought you meant wrapped like
oh no like eminem wraps yeah no i put a
w in front of it all right i've never
heard that i thought i saw him outside
in the in the wizard cloak just doing
you know just
yeah he could have done it he could have
done it
he could do anything that man
but do you do you guys would have been
there because i think there's footage of
you guys in the audience and i'll just
listen to him but
christopher lee was incredibly
incredibly moved by his experience and
also moved by the fact that he had
wrapped and he says this very earnest
very heartfelt thing of you know you
guys have created magic and you know you
guys are all legends and this will be
remembered forever and i remember
thinking at the time if this was anyone
else you'd kind of dismiss it but
christopher lee with his voice you're
just kind of like wow maybe he's on to
something here you know extraordinary
man well he's in his i mean he met
tolkien right yeah yeah he he he every
year yeah he
and he was uh i think
i think he was some sort of a spy or
something in the second world war
um he had some some
relationship to the war and and to
that that made it more special to him
because i think he was writing tolkien
was writing it during the war and
sending chapters to his son christopher
in in europe or something like in in the
main land i don't know yeah i think
anyhow i think i might be getting this
wrong but i think christopher lee was in
the sas and was working behind enemy
lines in the second world war and one of
certainly my favorite story about
christopher lee's and i think elijah's
as well
was elijah and i were with him on
location somewhere outside
and he and he said we were just chatting
about something and he and he said watch
this and he took a big pen
and threw it into a tree and it's stuck
in the tree like a knife wow and i
remember thinking if that was a knife
that tree would be a goner yeah he
turned a pen into a deadly weapon so he
was quite an intimidation
amazing
he took me under his wing a lot and we
we smoked cigars together nice yeah and
uh he he yeah and we were we were in
france at one point
and he took me along the champs-elysees
there was some sort of a gentleman's
club
not like that no
like no not like that like
a place where gentlemen would go it's
like a way
station
in your day when you're doing paris to
to be among
you know uh
like-minded fellas you know deep
mahogany
paneling and um
smoke you know and he talked about we
went on the on the balcony and
overlooked the champs-elysees and he
talked about soldiers marching and but
anyhow yeah he was he was um
he's a legend yeah i was in i whenever i
got picked up in the morning very often
with you
i think they would pick you up first
generally
me second
and on this particular pickup there was
a little note on my call sheet that said
you will be picked up second and i
thought not sure why they've told me
that and it was an early start for me
five five past five something like that
so the person being picked up before me
would have been picked up at 4 35 or
something like that as i got into the
back seat christopher lee was in the
front seat on his first day i've never
met him before
i got in
noisy little you know
early 20 year old boy i said oh good
good morning christopher how's it going
my name's dominic and he turned around
and said i have never been picked up so
early for work in my entire career
and i just sat back just sunk into the
chair
no more from me for the next half an
hour i'll keep my mouth shut
yeah he's a fantastic guy now obviously
sean we we've we've gone over or you've
gone over uh with us and also
individually so many of these wrote
subjects what was it like to work with
elijah what's pete jackson like what was
your first impression of the film all
that kind of stuff are there still
things
that you would like to
be asked about with lautering still
things that need to be mined still
things that you have to say or at this
point are you like well i think most of
it's been said
you know it just depends on how people
interact with you you know i i don't
think i don't i don't know that i've got
a deep well of information that i that
like that if
you know after five thousand comic-con
appearances and whatever
wait
there's this one thing i haven't been
able to get to but but uh but to me it's
endlessly you know my father
um you guys never met my dad i don't
think john aston he was gomez in the
original adams family and he he um
he taught me as a very young
person that you know
people are not pieces on a chess board
and you
you know as much as i i like
strategy and
tactics with you know in business kind
of things or whatever but on a human
level people are
people are human beings are human beings
and every human interaction is sacred
that's what he always said to me and so
when i'm when i meet people depending on
who they are what's interesting to them
you know i try i usually will begin an
answer of something that we've talked
about so much and then try and make it
about them a little bit you know and
then and you you'll it is amazing though
when certain little i heard you you say
easter eggs sometimes don't like talk
about easter eggs
a little a little deep in the recess of
mine something will pop up that will
remind you yeah you know of oh right am
i that's right the smell of those sulfur
things that we you know those those
software beds i hadn't i hadn't
and you can smell them as soon as you
think about it you know yeah yeah uh you
know i always think about our helicopter
rights you know i should give you
permission to mock me you know it seems
it's
it's only fair no you're not gay because
of my guest
well i wonder if over time
now that we're all in our are you 50 yet
dom no i'm 44 but we're getting there
come on
come on i know billy's like 56 at this
point but anyhow at this point
now that you've known people like the
older you get like my father's 91 and we
talk a lot about how everyone he knew
his whole life is gone all of his
friends all the most the people he
worked with you know like there's when
you just it's like that so now we know
people who've who've died in in
accidents and you know whatever
are you any more even a little bit
sympathetic to my paranoia because i
existed in a state of extreme paranoia
for most of the
most of the shoot no of course of course
i'm sure well i think billy was much
more empathetic at the time i i am much
more now i think you know you obviously
mature and grow up i think a lot of that
with you came from the fact that you
were a young father and
none of us had children at that point so
you're probably much more aware of the
mortality of people with you being a
father and what's at stake for you there
was nothing at stake for me you know i
was 23 the naivety of me coming into
those films in a lot of ways saved me
because i had to adopt this very
carefree
silly
fly by the seat of your pants ready to
improvise ready to joke and laugh with
billy attitude and i think in a lot of
ways you had to adopt the right right
everyone stopped messing around i'm sam
i'm trying to get this person safe
you're just being loud and noisy over
there that's you know kind of what you
represented
as a hobbit but do you remember
remember okay so you did lost i'm you
must have gone up in helicopters when
you were doing yeah yeah often yeah
and and and and did you study how they
communicate the pilots sure
but i don't think billy have you done a
lot of helicopter flying yeah i like to
i like to get up in a helicopter once a
week at
least as my
my son said to me when he was very young
he says i reckon i could fly a
helicopter i don't know if i could land
it
i can play it i'd love to see that that
would be great i don't know why he said
that he was about
well he's been honest yeah right but as
a father you have to teach him yeah you
have to teach my life when you teach
them how to ride a bicycle you have to
show them how to stop first right
but they when we were shooting when we
were filming
i'm probably not going to be able to
adjudicate this moment in this setting
but because it's you guys
so
they tell us
at any moment the weather can change we
filmed at the tops of all these great
yeah for the listener right at the top
of these great mountain peaks that were
that was the most extraordinary thing
this being places where you know no
other human being has ever been in the
history of the
you know so uh but it could change so
they had they had sat a
um
you know one of those big
things that they have like in contact
with sites like a
a wheels again
a wheel
not a
like an office like one of those
portable offices one of those portals
you know i'm talking about yeah so and
they and they've thrown in there a bunch
of uh meal ready to eat type of things
that the military has and the bunsen
burner and some you know uh
sleeping bags and you know and there's
probably 30 of us up there
and they're like you know if
we have to evacuate and we can't
evacuate quickly enough right you're
gonna have to stay
huddled together
until the weather passes
which can be days
right this is what they told us they
they had to pre-position
stuff at the top of the mountain okay
one assume they didn't do this for their
health right they were doing it as an
emergency scenario so
so
then at a certain point
the
the people with the walkie-talkies
started looking very concerned and
saying the helicopters are coming in
we're gonna we're gonna stop for the day
and we just started yeah so we were
evacuating the
mountain yeah
and
you lot you and elijah you two and
elijah thought it was hilarious
so they were they were putting the
helicopter skid
on the edge of a rock the other skid
floating
right floating like if they would have
turned the power it would have dropped
so it's floating there so that we can
get in and we climb in and you guys are
laughing and laughing now they had at
least two i think three helicopters okay
look at billy i love you there's a lot
of those things a lot of this is great
so they're they're they're they're
there's no we're in the middle of
nowhere
we're in the middle of nowhere it took
an hour and a half to drive there in a
vehicle and these helicopters come in so
now they're not taking us back to the
place where the helicopters
like were would take off from the
airport the heliport or whatever
they took us right to the bottom of the
mountain the bottom of the mountain and
drop us off and go right back up to the
top of the mountain because i had to get
people off before the thing would come
in how exciting and the look and the
pilot's face
was very concerned
[Laughter]
this has left in you for a long time
yeah get
get it you need to get this story out
come on so yes the answer tom the answer
is yes so i had to get this out yes
there was one thing i had to get up
so so we're getting the three of you
guys are chattering away on the thing
now there's no like air traffic control
tower
okay there's no there's just what they
call
vrf visual flight what are the vfr
visual flight rules okay and the clouds
are coming in
and you guys are
jaw-jacking and now
now if you have been in a helicopter
since then
you know that the pilot can push his
button and the sound of you guys talking
gets a little bit lower yeah so that he
can talk to the other pilot yeah okay
does is it mutes the passengers
but it doesn't mute you it just lowers
your volume a little bit but you
compensated
the three of you
[Laughter]
you compensated for
let's go back to the start where they
built a thing for us to like be put in
with bunsen burners with the
with the bunsen burner that
so i had sleeping bags and a bunsen
bunny oh goodness me yeah cause you have
to cook the stuff in the package
you're not thinking maybe you get a
little miniature gas stove as opposed to
a bottle
you mean a little mini gas stove shawn
maybe
maybe not a bunsen yeah
so hopefully in this in this in this
conversation hopefully we've each
learned something but we're definitely
learning things sean
go on bills
oh god that's that's psyche that's been
like a little black butterfly flying
around your stomach but you have to
remember sean that um that that need for
safety wasn't just at the top of
mountains i remember we were in a i
think it was a rugby game me and you had
gone to see a rugby game for some reason
was it do you remember that
it was me very well me and you were
sitting in this stadium watching a rugby
game and all of a sudden he went quiet
it's not like sean and i said sean
are you are you working out emergency
exits for us if something happens and he
was like yeah
and he was sitting working out if if
there was a bomb over there i can get
out this way if there was
if i if a monsoon came in
he was working all out in his head that
was brilliant i could see all of us grow
up with hooliganism and the instinct on
how to flee some of us have to
train for it my my vague recollection of
that day and you're right sean to be
careful and try and keep us safe and all
that kind of stuff but my vague
recollection of that day was yeah we
were brought down to a kind of halfway
house
and myself and billy and elijah were
throwing stones and then trying to have
the second stone hit the stone that we
threw do you remember that we were just
killing time yeah so you'd throw a big
stone and then we were trying to throw
the next stone and we were goofing
around waiting and it was cold and we
were waiting for a helicopter coming in
and then we all became the three of us
became distracted by sean who stepped
away from the group straight not
throwing stones doing this
to helicopters
bringing people in
no no no no okay okay oh that's
backwards sean that's my memory as well
and in
you're most you're you're largely
correct but
there's a substantial difference right
all i was doing
was pointing to the
pilot
oh my god i can see that i could see the
pilot behind him
and you know what the pilot
so you were letting the first pilot know
that you could see the second pilot
that's exactly right
so that he didn't back up into him hey
kid he didn't back up into him
can a helicopter go in reverse
they can pick up and do this very
quickly have you never played a video
game but sean do you not think that both
of those helicopter pilots might have
been in cahoots with each other on a
radio that you might not have needed to
tell that helicopter pilot number one
that his mate is behind him they're
chatting they're tiring that's why we
were laughing at you because we were
going what are you doing
i'm telling him that he sees him
and then i do remember us
come on
i remember the pilots i got some
feedback from my act my activity my
action there
i got a thumbs up from the pilot oh
lovely stuff lovely stuff i got a thumbs
up a little tenfold which could have
been a thumbs up
no because he didn't help him find
anything
hold on
moving on from then i remember being the
four of us being in the helicopter and i
was chatting and i remember one moment
of sean kind of
giving us a bit of a
stern earphone you know something like
guys be quiet and elijah kind of went
we're in trouble i do remember that
moment
but you know what you said
very very clearly and you know what you
said
don't you think that the pilot and his
mate are in communication with each
other
and i and i said
they're trying
hey dom that was good one that was great
wasn't that lovely talking to sean i was
in hysterics when he was talking about
the helicopter thing yeah he's funny
he's a he's a very funny man actually
yeah he is goofy goofy yeah i really
like him he's one of the goodens he's a
good human being his heart has always
been in the right place and in that
situation with the helicopter all he's
trying to do
is earnestly keep us safe yeah and the
three of us i think are in a headspace
of
cat mom we're having fun and he's like
no this is a serious situation i
actually could all go yeah so could go
wrong so it's important at times to look
at people's uh point of view but it's
great it's great hearing the stories i
really like them yeah good that was
really great lovely that was too much
for one show so we'll cut it there
we'll see him again next week yeah along
with everybody else who's listening or
watching
that's true we talked about so much and
it went on for so long and we had so
much fun that there's just a little bit
too much for one episode so
part one this week part two next week
let us know if you're enjoying it rate
review and subscribe to the friendship
onion where you get your podcast and on
our youtube channel and on our spotify
playlist there has been a few comments
about problems finding our spotify
playlist that's because lots of people
have created their own
the friendship onion playlist but if you
keep digging and digging and digging
you'll find the official one
oh so there you are also you can send us
emails at the friendship onion at
castmedia.com
yeah and uh please enjoy
yourself
and the rest of your week the rest of
your week and we'll see you anon
doodles bye-bye
[Music]